Cocoa's Pixar's new Day of the Dead
themed animation and the first trailer
just dropped giving us a fantastic look
at some of the characters we can look
forward to meeting in the movie
yippee-ki-yay movie lovers it's Jan here
and in this video I'm going to break
down the first trailer for Coco and
reveal some hidden details you might
have missed the trailer opens on a scene
of Miguel entering an ofrenda or shrine
for his musical hero
Ernesto that are growth inside the
shrine there are tons of pictures
records and lots of dlc mentions which
is of course short for della growth and
there's also two handmade signs that
read dlc por siempre which in english
means dlc forever there are lots of nice
touches at pixar put into designing this
traditional Mexican or frienda in other
words a type of altar set up on the Day
of the Dead to honor the memory of a
person's ancestors we can see orange and
yellow marigolds which of the flowers
traditionally used in an offer endow
other cool details include a plate of
food with what looks like a sweet bread
or pan dulce on top of which is a
Calavera or mexican candied skull and
that's because in enough render the
favorite food of the deceased is
typically offered to make the deceased
person feel welcome and comfortable next
Miguel puts on a video cassette of some
old black-and-white recordings of his
idol Ernesto the rock Ruth who's voiced
by actor Benjamin Bratt you might have
seen brass on screen recently as
Jonathan Pangborn in Doctor Strange and
his character in Coco is inspired by
legendary Mexican film and musical icons
such as pedro infante jorge negrete and
Vicente Fernandez okay let's move on to
the next scene where we see Miguel
unfolding a torn photo with the face of
one person missing what we already know
about Coco is that Miguel comes from a
family of shoemakers the Rivera's who
banned music and the family after
Miguel's great-great-grandma that amenda
was abandoned by her husband after he
left to chase his musical dreams this
picture is probably of Miguel's
great-great grandparents and their
daughter mama Coco who is Miguel's
great-grandmother and judging by the
broken picture frame on the floor it
seems the Miguel may have chanced upon
this photo literally by accident
given this comes straight after the
previous scene of Ana stood across on TV
serenading a woman
it seems implied that the missing
character from the photo is the deceased
in a nest or so perhaps this photo is
the reason why we next see Miguel
breaking into Anastos tomb as he's
trying to uncover something about his
family's past
inside the tomb Miguel
Caeser Anastos old guitar and as he
touches it the flowers on the floor
light up suggesting miguel shares a
special connection with ernesto by the
way this moment and the way the flowers
light up and rise up around him reminds
me somewhat of the 2016 animated movie
Kubo and the two strings and this
special connection is what transports
Miguel to the underworld together with
his dog Dante who by the way is a
shallow also known as a Mexican hairless
dog actually the fact that the dog is
named Dante seems highly appropriate
given the themes of the movie as
medieval Italian poet Dante's famous
work the Divine Comedy was all about the
author's travels through the realms of
the Dead finally the trailer ends with a
lovely first look at the underworld in
cocoa the multicolored design and other
worldliness of it reminded me a bit of
inside-out which then left me wondering
where the Pixar might include a cameo by
Bing bong here in the land of the dead
Bing bong heroically sacrificed himself
to save joy from being trapped inside
Riley's memory dump and it would be
wonderful to see him or any other
deceased Pixar characters appear in
Coco's underworld
talking of connections to other Pixar
movies the inspiration for Coco actually
kind of came from a scene at the end of
Toy Story 3 Coco director Lee Unkrich
who also directed Toy Story 3 told e.w
that at the end of Toy Story 3 we had
this moment where Jesse's horse turns on
the boombox and the Gypsy Kings do a
spanish-language version of you've got a
friend in me which it turned out ended
up being a real precursor to this movie
now obviously there have been Day of the
Dead themed animations before including
the 2014 film The Book of Life but I
still can't wait to see Pixar's own take
on the theme so what did you think about
the first teaser trailer for Pixar's
Coco and are there any dead Pixar
characters you'd like to see appear in
Coco's land of the dead I'd love to hear
your thoughts in the comments below and
if you enjoyed this video do please hit
those like and share buttons and why not
subscribe for more of my Pixar and
Disney videos you can also tap or click
here to watch some more of my videos you
might like thanks for watching and see
you next time
yippee-ki-yay movie lovers